dans ces petits carrés se cache l'une
des dernières créations de la maison une
ganache chocolat noir à la fleur
d'oranger nous sommes sur la dernière
étape de fabrication l'enrobage qui
donnera un aspect brillant au chocolat
il ne reste plus qu'à les décorer
et après donc on vient appliquer
donc la petite douille cannelée qui
finit donc la signature donc le décor on
appelle ça des décors des bonbons qui
permet d'avoir quelque chose de bien
fini direction ensuite le tunnel de
froid à 15 degrés pour les saisir avant
de les conditionner il faut trois jours
pour fabriquer un chocolat un an pour
mettre au point une recette on travaille
les produits bruts de base et on les
transforme de A à Z en fait donc on n'a
pas de de de choses
à acheter comme la plupart de des
maisons où ils ne peuvent pas fabriquer
leur base c'est à dire le praliné les
pâtes d'amandes etc ce qui sont pas le
matériel
sur la chaîne de production à côté une
autre spécialité sort tout juste de
cuisson la nougatine donc là on fait des
bandes et après une fois que une fois
que ça va refroidir
c'est un bonbon qui va se détacher un
par un
des ouvriers travaillent jusqu'à 200 kg
de matière chaque jour il faut gérer pas
trop chaud non plus faut vraiment gérer
la température
donc là on travaille on est à peu près
50 60 degrés là
ces bonbons seront bientôt
commercialisés à travers la France et
même au-delà de nos frontières soit en
sorte de confiserie et chocolats sont
élaborés ici chaque année leur secret de
fabrication n'a jamais été percé depuis
le 17e siècle